[Music]
so
[Music]
hello professor uh happy 60th birthday
and wish you the best of health
yan thank you
ayan i wish you a very happy 60th
birthday
i hope you have a great day and an
awesome year
and also i hope you keep uh making the
world wiser and uh
bringing it closer to solving ai once
again i hope you have a lot of fun
enjoy yourself thanks bye
hello yan happy birthday i can't believe
it's your 60th birthday already
uh your 50th does not seem like that
long ago
um thank you so much for all of your
support and teaching over the years it's
meant a lot to me
i hope you have a great day and i hope
that it's a great decade to come
and that i get to see you soon in person
bye
happy birthday young wishing you have a
wonderful year being sixties
thanks for everything you did your
revolutionary idea changed the world
you also inspired a lot of people pursue
a career in ai
including me looking forward to talk to
you again
bachelorettesies hi yan
happy birthday from alaska i wish you a
great year
full of happiness that make you small
like this
caribou tooth i found here
happy birthday jan i hope you're
celebrating by listening to
awesome jazz music on your sailboat
in brittany with lots of birds and
nice fish whatever makes you happy it's
always a pleasure to talk with to you
about everything science of the world or
whatever and i look forward to doing
that for many years to come
bye thanks for being a great teacher
a great mentor and i hope you're having
a great birthday right now
happy birthday yeah so grateful for
working with you
wish you all the best for the coming
year
happy birthday yan wishing you a happy
and healthy 60th birthday from montreal
hey um i wanted to wish you a wonderful
birthday and upcoming year of wisdom
and i hope that you have a delicious
cake with lots of filling
and not too many cherries take care and
see you soon
happy birthday wishing you an abundance
of
good health and all the things that you
love
and to keep inspiring people around the
world
[Music]
hey young this is jake greetings from
china
i think we all know that the world has
become a better place because of you for
the last 60 years
and i feel so lucky to know you and have
worked with you happy birthday
happy birthday thanks for being a great
advisor not just academically but also
by always making us feel like you have
our back
thank you for our patient guidance and
we're really looking forward to working
with you in amazing research for many
years to come
and it's a great honor to work with you
hi anne it seems like only yesterday we
were having a 60th birthday dinner for
jeff and it's unfortunate that we can't
get together and have a big celebration
for you this year
due to the the current pandemic but i do
wish you all the very best
for your birthday and for the year ahead
hi yan i would like to wish you all the
best for your birthday
um i wanted to tell you that the times
that i
spent in nyu as your postdoc
was uh one of the most wonderful
research times
in my career
i wish you all the best and
i do hope that
you will be very proud
of all your students and postdocs and
that we will follow your
footsteps to uh contribute
to the research field with interesting
and inspirational works
happy birthday hey ann happy birthday
um thanks for everything thanks for
making silver
such a nice and welcoming place thanks
for making fair such an
awesome incredible place um
thanks for sharing your ideas with us
and inspiring us
uh i mean it's awesome to work with you
and
i am super happy to get to
continue to see what you will do and to
continue to
collaborate with you in the future so
happy birthday again
happy birthday anne i wish you many
exciting years ahead and thank you for
everything
happy birthday yon it's been a pleasure
working with you so far this summer and
looking forward to much more to come
my
[Applause]
happy success birthday young
you